la cuna ya no es la moneda oficial de
Croacia el país balcánico entra en 2023
y adopta el euro el mismo día que pasa a
formar parte del espacio xiangan y el
pasaporte dejará de ser necesario entre
los países comunitarios
es el primer país en la historia en
introducir las dos reformas al mismo
tiempo
creo que logramos no solo un importante
prioridad de política exterior sino
también un objetivo nacional y
estratégico
sin embargo hay recelo La cuna es un
símbolo de la independencia de Croacia
después de la Guerra de los balcanes fue
adoptada el 30 de mayo de 1994
el verdadero problema es que al entrar
en la eurozona Croacia pierde la última
forma de su soberanía no tenemos ninguna
posibilidad de influir en el mundo pero
para otros el cambio significa problemas
logísticos ya se han eliminado un tercio
de los cajeros donde se podían retirar
las cunas
hay descuentos por pagos en efectivo en
algunos lugares y cuando no tenemos
efectivo Necesitamos ir a un cajero
automático buscarlo vamos allí como
ahora y está fuera de servicio
otros ya estaban acostumbrados al Euro
creo que irá muy bien porque el euro ya
era parte de nuestra vida cambiábamos
cunas por euros teníamos cuentas de
ahorro en euros nos acostumbraremos como
nos acostumbramos a otros cambios
pese a las dificultades los expertos
financieros auguran una mayor protección
para la economía croata
tenemos un costo único de alrededor de
100 millones de euros para todo el
proceso de transición al Euro en el lado
positivo ya no tendremos riesgo
cambiario Gracias el país número 20 en
adoptar el euro pero todavía con vivirá
hasta el 14 de enero con las cunas ese
día desaparecerán para siempre